it's a great pleasure for me to meet to
introduce my friend of nearly 30 years
standing David McCullough since David is
one of those rare people who genuinely
does not need an introduction I would
just like to say something about him
that you may have forgotten we now think
of David as our unofficial national
biographer and national historian before
he became those things David was the
best writer of description descriptive
nonfiction about construction who's a
whom I have ever read his book the great
bridge about the building of the
Brooklyn Bridge
and it booked the path between the Seas
about the construction of the Panama
Canal or absolute masterpieces if you
haven't read them you must ladies and
gentlemen David McCullough
[Applause]
goodness me
thank you thank you John to have a
Pulitzer Prize book reviewer who has
been writing some of the finest reviews
of anyone in this country for what is it
20 30 years that's John Yardley and if
you don't read his reviews you shut
their their works of literature unto
themselves and his beautiful wife Marie
Arana is one of the reasons that we have
this great book festival because of her
support in the Washington Post she's the
editor of the post terrific book
magazine book world I'm I'm so indebted
to the Library of Congress for so many
reasons for 40 years I've been using the
library as a source but also as a as an
inspiration my my first inkling about
doing a book and about trying something
that I had never done before
came because I saw some material
photographic material in the Library of
Congress which led me to write my first
book and I have been helped by inspired
by set on the right path by the staff
many people on the staff of the library
all these years I also believe fervently
in the Public Library System we have I
think it's one of our greatest of all
institutions I'm sure you agree
I think that the portals of public
libraries are the portals to freedom to
to the open mind as well as to the open
stacks and it's it's so reassuring to
tour the country as I have this summer
and see wonderful new libraries in our
major cities and to hear that library
use is up and to be reminded again and
again how fortunate we are in this
country no other country has a system
public library system such as we have
and if you ever get down about the state
of American civilization or the American
arts or whatever just keep one small
statistic in mind we still have more
public libraries in this country than
there are McDonald's
now sitting somewhere in this oh there
you are in this great crowd is my
editor-in-chief and I want you to know
that she has been a driving force great
corrector of bad grammar poor spelling
and a a constant believer in what I'm
trying to do for 50 years
my wife Rosalie
she is the Mission Control and Secretary
of the Treasury and chair of the ethics
committee I have I have traveled all
over the country this summer 26 cities
on the book tour the people say to me
why do you do that well I do it because
I love it I love to meet people who who
love books and who read what I do and I
love to see what's going on and to hear
what's on people's minds and to just
shake their hands and find out what they
think of my work and some of them will
say memorable things like the fellow who
leaned over too many who said I'll bet
you did a lot of research for that
and then there was another man that's
quite true in Atlanta who came through
the came through the line and he had a
copy of my 1776 he said I just I really
liked this book he said now notice how
beautiful the jacket is and he said
inside here there are all these
wonderful illustrations they're as good
as an in art book any page through them
like this he was showing them to me as
if I'd never seen the book that word and
he said then there's that picture on the
back that's good too he said but I just
have one question I thought oh boy
what's it going to be he said where'd
you get that sport coat
the the Revolutionary War era the 18th
century was more important to who we are
and the way we are and what we hold to
be our American secular faith than most
people realize and unfortunately to a
very large degree it is portrayed so
often almost as though the people who
were involved and particularly the
protagonists were figures in a costume
pageant the the clothing of the time the
renditions of Jefferson and Washington
and others in the paintings by Gilbert
Stuart or Charles Wilson Peale lend this
sort of theatrical quality to them we
don't see them in photographs
we have no recordings of their voices we
we can't we can't see film footage of
them and in fact in the case of those
who fought in the war
we have no on-the-spot drawings by
artists correspondents such as Winslow
Homer who covered the Civil War so that
it's it's almost impossible to reach
them as we would reach people in the
Civil War or the First World War or
others except for what they wrote what
they wrote in Diaries and letters and
sometimes orderly books records of one
kind or another
and memoirs or autobiographies written
after the fact the newspaper coverage
was nothing like we would expect there
were no correspondents covering the war
no reportage coming back to be published
in the papers around the country
and and by and large we would have to
conclude we don't know what they look
like
but we can do we do know what they look
like in part because of deserter notices
when men deserted from the ranks when
they went home or they went over
defected went over to the other side
notices would be published in the papers
or end up at store coke
country stores and they were very
descriptive because they hope to find
these people and what comes through in
those descriptions is a realization of
how different from all of us they looked
very few who fought with Washington have
marched with Washington and 1776 war
uniforms even the officers rarely had
full uniforms Washington himself at a
magnificent uniform because he felt that
that was part of his role as a leader to
look like the leader to look like the
general but the men in the ranks were
wearing everything imaginable and they
and they were not supplied with
replacements for what they wore so as
the year wore on their clothing became
tattered mended dirty eventually in rags
or worse than rags the and the times
themselves the era in which they lived
was so much harder than we understand a
life life for someone in the 18th
century even in peacetime was very
difficult by our standards very
uncomfortable filled with with danger
threats of disease filled with the
possible accidents and and physical
destruction that could come from work
now people were beat up by life more
than we are in our time there were no
orthodontist no dentists
no cosmetic surgeons to say the least
that someone with a severe childhood
injury like Nathaniel Greene would walk
for the rest of his life with a limp
coming from an accident that in our time
would be readily corrected John Trumbull
the great painter whose whose works hang
in the Capitol the signing of the
Declaration of Independence the
magnificent painting of one of the most
important scenes in our history when
Washington returned command of the army
back to the Congress returned his power
to the Congress something no conquering
general had ever done after the end of
the Revolutionary War John Trumbull only
had the use of one eye again because of
a childhood injury Henry Knox had part
of one hand blown off in a hunting
accident as a young man and on and on
people were missing teeth they had a
cast in their eye or they had a way of
holding their head on their shoulder
because of something had happened to
them
life was dangerous difficult and people
were resilient tough and strong to a
degree that is something we too seldom
forget we in our time we're soft ease by
contrast we we it's hard for us to
imagine what it would be like to have
sweeping epidemic dysentery or smallpox
or typhus or typhoid sweep through our
town or community or city and take the
lives of hundreds of people all around
us but it happened and of course when
the war came on the suffering and the
and the tragedy and the grief the sorrow
can't be measured with any statistics
Abigail Adams said future generations
who will reap the blessings we'll have
little idea can little imagine what we
have suffered in their behalf and she
was right the war was the longest in our
history except for the Vietnam War eight
and a half years it was also very bloody
proportionate to the population
twenty-five thousand Americans were
killed now to us two we who have lived
with the brutal statistics of the 20th
and 21st centuries of war casualties and
suffering worldwide 25,000 doesn't sound
like a great deal but 25,000 was one
percent of a population of two million
five hundred thousand and if we were to
fight a Revolutionary War today with our
population that would mean that over
three million would be killed so in
their time it was a horrible war and it
was extremely costly to the people who
stayed home and had to make do without
their husbands to work the farm or to be
the breadwinner for a family now I'd
like to just read you a little bit from
some of these deserter notices they're
very colorful they're very picturesque
in a way they are describing people who
are immediately identifiable in a way
that we're not used to very much like
the characters in Dickens say one George
Reynolds of Rhode Island for example was
five feet nine and a half inches tall
age seventeen Jimmy and carried his head
something on his right shoulder Thomas
Williams was an immigrant an old country
man this says in quotes that means he
was from the old country he wasn't an
old man from the country he was from
probably Ireland or Wales or somewhere
that kind he spoke good English but had
a film in his left eye
David Relf a saucy fellow was wearing a
white coat jacket and breeches and
ruffled shirt when last seen deserted
from Colonel Brewster's regiment and
captain Harvey's company said a notice
in the Essex Connecticut Gazette one
Simeon Smith of Greenfield a joiner by
trade a thin spared fellow about 5 feet
4 inches high head on a blow blue coat
in the black vest a metal button on his
hat black long hair black eyes his voice
in the hermaphrodite fashion the
masculine rather predominant likewise
Matthias Smith a small smart fellow a
Sadler by trade gray headed as a younger
look in his face and is apt to say I
swear I swear and between his words will
spit smart head on a green coat and an
old red gray coat he's got wearing to
coach you see ones red ones green he's a
right gamester although he wears
something of a sober look like wise John
Day be a long hump shouldered fellow a
shoemaker by trade draws his words and
for comfortable says comfortable he had
on a green coat thick leather breeches
slim legs lost some of his four teeth
these men who are largely anonymous were
the ones who went and did the hard
marching and fighting and marching and
fighting again and again
month after month and who made the words
the noble ideals of the Declaration of
Independence more than just a
declaration more than just words on
paper when we celebrate the 4th of July
we celebrate the great openings passages
of the Declaration of Independence we
celebrate that all men are created equal
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness none of that would have been
possible without the men who marched
with Washington through 1776 and beyond
and don't picture them as all heroes
they weren't hundreds deserted thousands
deserted as time went on
thousands more went home when their
enlistments were up they only enlisted
for a year and when the time came to go
home nothing there was nothing to stop
them and many of them just marched away
when Washington was in retreat across
New Jersey and his army was down to rags
and many of the men were without shoes
and winter was coming on and the British
were coming on fast behind them in in in
force beyond anything that Washington
could even imagine with soldiers who
were well trained well shod with good
clothes good equipment when that was
going on at one point in in December
2000 the enlistments for 2,000 men came
up and 2,000 men marched away went home
with no shame Washington's army was down
to 3,000 men that's all that were left
so in effect quite literally we owe what
we have and who we are and all that we
hold sacred to about 3,000 men who would
not quit
and that was because in part they were
led by a man who would not quit George
Washington was not a great intellectual
like Jefferson or Adams or Hamilton he
wasn't a brilliant speaker like Ally
like his fellow Virginian Patrick Henry
what George Washington was was a leader
he was a man of phenomenal courage
physical and moral courage he was a man
who could spot great talent in other
people and give them a chance and two of
the best men he picked he picked within
about two weeks after first meeting them
Nathaniel Greene and Henry Knox and he
picked them despite the fact that he
they were New Englanders and he disliked
New Englanders ardently he thought they
were the best he had and they were the
best he had those two men Greene and
Knox with Washington were the only
general officers who stayed the entire
length of the war who did not leave who
would not quit Washington also had the
capacity to understand how our system
works that he was not the boss that
Congress was the boss and he was serving
at the will of Congress at the pleasure
of Congress and one of the best things
that Congress ever did the Congress of
the United States ever did was to pick
Washington as the commander in chief now
keep in mind please they did not pick
him because he was a great General
Washington had never commanded an army
in his life in battle before taking
command in Cambridge in 17 summer of 75
and when he took command he was all of
43 don't pictures these leaders as elder
statesmen of the kind we see in the
Gilbert Stuart paintings they were young
men Washington was 43 Adams was 40
Hancock was 39 Jefferson was all of 33
when he wrote the Declaration of
Independence this was a young man's
revolution a young man's cause and
Washington being a member of Congress
was known by the other others in
Congress and they picked him because of
his character
they knew the man and they knew they
could trust him and when the war was
over and Washington did return the
command to the Congress he did something
that had never been done before
when George the 3rd was told that
Washington might do this George the 3rd
said if he does that he will be the
greatest man in the world and he stood
back from power as he had promised to do
in the beginning but the real story it
seems to me are is with those men and
rags who marched with him when his army
finally got to the Delaware River and
crossed the Delaware River at night
trying to put the river between them and
the oncoming British army they were men
were utterly exhausted most of them were
sick they were all hungry they were they
were cold they had no winter clothing
they were in rags many of them had their
feet wrapped in rags because they had no
shoes and the stories of men leaving
bloody footprints in the snow from their
bare feet are not mythical that is the
truth that's what it was they crossed
the river and the next morning a militia
unit from Philadelphia they come up to
relieve them to help them included
Charles Wilson Peale the painter who was
at that time a young officer with the
militia unit and he said he'd never seen
such miserable human beings in his life
these poor ragged soldiers who had been
fighting again and again at losing again
and again to the British and he was
walking among them and he saw one man
who was all but naked except for a
blanket coat as they were called who was
so dirty so filthy his hair down over
his shoulders that he couldn't tell
whether he was a black or white or what
or who he was in his face was all
covered with sores and peel wrote in his
diary that he'd never seen a more
wretched human being in
his life and then a few minutes later he
realized that the man was his own
brother
in a way they are all our own brothers
and we as their descendants if you will
are forever in their debt we must never
forget them we must never not recognize
how much we owe to them and among the
things that we must do is know about
them learn about them tell our children
about them encourage our children and
our grandchildren to read about them and
to know what they went through these
were not characters in a costume pageant
they were human beings as real and as
alive as we are and all that they did
for our country is also of course part
of what is stirring much of the world
Rosalee and I have just come back from
Hungary from Budapest and the Hungarians
are about to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of the Hungarian Revolution
of 1956 and they were very interested to
hear about the revolution of 1776
because they considered that too part of
what is their heritage as well as ours
thank you very much
thank you very much
we're live back at the National Book
Festival with David McCullough he's
agreed to take some phone calls from our
viewers we go to Lakeland Florida first
go ahead Lakeland mr. David I'm Doug de
Rogers I wanted to ask the question that
I never hear George Washington was a
free and accepted Mason over 50 of the
people that signed the Declaration of
Independence were free and accepted
Mason's
most of them were wealthy men they were
persecuted for doing this and over 15
presidents have been free and accepted
basements why do we never hear anything
about free and accepted Mason they
helped develop this country and they
help to win the or 1776 well I don't
think that's quite right I think we do
hear about that
heard a lot about it all my life my
father was amazingly he talked about it
and I read it again and again
here in Washington of course across the
river in Alexandria the great monument
to Washington's participation in the
basis it was a very important part of
his his life and I think an important
part of the of the position that he held
in the minds of many people and he meant
his country in his time Los Angeles go
ahead mr. McCullough enjoyed your talk
and can't wait to read your book thank
you I wonder if he could touch on Thomas
Paine's involvement at the Battle of the
Trenton and I would like to know if he
was present there if he was a North
Washington in Trenton no Thomas Paine
marched with Washington in the retreat
from New York across New Jersey and that
was when he supposedly wrote his famous
lines about these are the times that try
men's souls writing them on a on a drum
by the light of the fire at night but in
fact he wrote his famous statement in
Philadelphia it was published in I think
December 8th of that year and he was not
at Trenton but he was certainly with
them in spirit what does it mean to you
to be a historian today
well I think it means probably what it
meant to be an historian in any age
you're trying as best you can to
understand what happened in times past
but also to be as accurate and as close
to the reality of other times and the
events of other times but also to keep
it alive and I feel that it's very
important that historians do all they
can to write as well as they possibly
can because if history isn't well
written if it isn't if it isn't
appealing as literature if if it can
come to that which you aspire to then
history will die if you squeeze all the
life out of it and the color out of it
and you make it dull if you make it
boring you're not only doing a
disservice to the reader
doing a disservice to the collective
memory of our society and you're doing a
disservice to the events themselves
because they were never dull boring part
colorless well speaking of never felt
boring akela as we were talking with
Joseph al
earlier about taking today on the mall
here and thinking back of what it would
have been like in the earlier period
speaking particularly of the
anti-war rally that just went on up here
about five blocks away and the pro-war
rally that's going to go on here yeah
I'm here tomorrow well I think that if
the founders were to come back and they
were to see what's going on right here
now I think they would be very happy
because they'd see that the system of
government that they put in place still
works still stands they would see that
freedom of expression is still very much
alive they would see that this city
named for General President Washington
is still the capital of the nation and
in many ways of the world and they would
feel that they've done pretty well and
of course some of it they would
recognize that John Adams so would know
recognize the Congress John Adams who
was the first president to occupy the
White House would certainly think that
it was much improved since his time
since it was barely still under
construction
anything but finished when he moved in
but the words that he said in his first
letter to his wife Abigail written from
the White House are carved in the
mantelpiece over the fireplace in the
State Dining Room I'm a nun but but
honest and wise men ever rule beneath
this roof and it was put there by
Franklin Roosevelt and it's a reminder
of how how much history there is just in
that building just in that place this we
live in a very interesting country
and one of the what part of the magic of
Washington isn't just at these
magnificent open spaces are here and all
these wonderful museums and monuments
and the rest but that history is all
around you here you're walking on
historic ground wherever you go in this
city and that's I think why is so very
important to bring youngsters here to
bringing children here I think we've got
to do a much better job of teaching our
children history not just our teachers
teaching history in a more alive and
appealing way but we as parents and
grandparents and one of the ways you do
that is take them to historic places
don't wait for the school trip take them
bring them to Washington take them to
see the Concord bridge Massachusetts
there to Gettysburg
wherever they'll never forget it I know
I it really affected my life as a
youngster going to historic places with
my parents or friends of the parents who
would take us here and their friend of
mine on a spring vacation when we are
about 14 asked me to go with his mother
and father from Pittsburgh where I grew
up down to see Monticello and I had
never been out of Pittsburgh in my life
until there and that trip that visit to
Charlottesville changed my life I know
that that's where my interest in history
began Keene New Hampshire you're next
with David McCullough hey Dave how's it
going my name's Aaron I'm aspiring
student at a college and hopefully a
historian one day and I'm not doing my
study so I can watch book TV but I'd
like to ask you a question about George
Washington as a general I know that he
was a strong figure would you ever
compare him to the leadership qualities
that say a more modern general like
George Patton like does that make any
sense
was he ever brutal as Patton was or did
he have the same convictions that that
patented during the revolution well he
was a very different man from George
Patton he was a very
much more restrained and
calm in the in the midst of storm
Washington was not a great strategist or
tactician he wasn't another Napoleon and
he wasn't the most brilliant general
this country has ever had but he had
qualities that are essential you know in
a leader the strength of character
courage intelligence good health he was
healthy when everybody else was
succumbing to disease and ailments of
one kind another all around and he
wouldn't give up he wouldn't quit he
also had an ability to play the part of
the commanding general and he would talk
about that with his junior officers you
have to not only pack the part you have
to look
and history has cast you in a role of
great importance and you're gonna be
judged in time to come not by how well
you play that role one of the important
things about a sense of history is it
doesn't just give you an idea of what
happened before you came along but it
gives you the realization that what your
own actions are going to be judged in
the future because someday you're gonna
be part of history and that was a very
important part of their whole outlook on
life at that time they didn't have a
great sense of history of American
history because there wasn't much
American history and American history
hadn't been written yet their history
was classical history Greek and Roman
history and their ideas of Honor of
virtue of character character is a Greek
word they're ideas of the good Society
all came fundamentally from classical
history
because of what's going on in the South
I grabbed one of your older books hey
I'm surprised it's been 37 years since
you wrote this or since it was published
yes indeed it's has never been out of
print
I'm glad any idea how many you've sold
over the years I have no idea no I think
how do you compare what you learned with
the Johnstown Flood with what's going on
today in terms of the aftermath of
government response
well some of its the same the Red Cross
moved in there in to Johnstown after the
disaster took place on just as the Red
Cross has moved into a Louisiana and
other parts of the Gulf devastation area
I guess the principle similarity is that
the the problems the the deficiencies
the lack of responsibility that caused
the Johnstown Flood we're all reported
all spoken about long before it happened
and warnings were clear that if there
were heavy storms this might the dam in
the mountains might break Johnstown
Flood was caused by a dam breaking in
the mountains of western Pennsylvania
and when the dam broke a wall of water
came down the valley of the connemara
River the wall of water was anywhere
from 30 to 80 feet high depending on the
width of the island 15 miles until it
hit the city of Johnstown it took out
everything in front of it and when it
hit the city of Johnstown it destroyed
the entire city over 2,000 fatalities
well closer to 3,000 worst disaster and
has to be the country until then
and if there was a lesson to it it was
that it was perilous to assume that
people in positions of responsibility
are therefore behaving responsibly and
the dam was owned by many of the
wealthiest most powerful people in the
country pricks felons for [ __ ] people
in Johnstown assumed that if likes of
those people on the dam it was safe the
people who own the dam assumed that the
engineer who was in charge of the dam
charge of maintenance and upkeep on the
dam knew what he was doing and therefore
it that he said it was all right it was
all right but the owner of the mills in
Johnstown the cambrian company made
warning willing to accept that attitude
so they sent up their best engineer this
was years before the dam broke and he
took he spelled out exactly what was
wrong with the dam and forecast exactly
what would happen if it were ever to
break and
in a few years after his report the
president cambion cometh Daniel J
Burrell died it was like a Greek tragedy
all the four warnings were there just as
they have all been in New Orleans all
along it's not something just recently
it's been there all along
the reports of saying exactly what would
happen we we aren't we aren't able to
control natural calamities but we have
to accept the fact that they do happen
they will happen and we are not entirely
in charge and that we have to be
prepared for them and it's not easy my
feeling about the current tragedy is
that we should wait until we pass
judgment until we know more we don't
just wait yes wait a while because very
many of the things that were charged
said the claims made in the press after
the Jonestown disaster turned out to be
either not true or greatly exaggerated
and so the
we're all to blame and we're all
responsible for doing a better job from
now on not just our political leaders
who are our representatives we're all
responsible just as we're all
responsible for alleviating suffering
poverty and injustice we're all
responsible Mesa Arizona go ahead Mesa
Arizona please go ahead Mason one last
chance we lost that phone call what's
the bet how long have you been on the
tour for this for 1776 well I was on
tour about a month and a half I went to
26 cities I enjoyed it all and I came
back feeling very reassured about the
state of libraries in our country and
reading and the general attitude of
people about their communities and and
the the improvements that are being made
let's try the historic city of
Philadelphia next hello Philly yellow
you're on the air Philadelphia yes thank
you for all your work read and recommend
and give your books as gifts but I'm
calling on behalf of my old friend
Benjamin Thompson whom you mentioned in
1776 and you indicate that he went off
to Europe and changed his name and was
really at that title that as I'm sure
you're aware he had been given a title
by the by the Holy Roman Emperor for a
work of a lot of work that he did
particularly in Munich and Bavaria a
work that alleviated a lot of the health
problems that you've discussed so
thoroughly in the book and I was just
kind of wondering I guess what you know
why I sort of took that as a little bit
of a sort of a little bit of a shot that
at mr. Thompson Herbert no I didn't I
didn't mean it in any way critically of
him I just he was not known as Thompson
thereafter and I know exactly what
you're talking about
I thought think Thompson xx most
interesting man how the $0.18 one of the
most simple thing back
and of course as someone who was a
loyalist at heart he was by no means
alone about a third of their country
we're still loyal to the king we're
Tories and loyalists and those who were
in favor of the revolution probably were
about a third and the remaining third
were in the good old human way waiting
to see who won Los Angeles go ahead oh
my on you're on okay fellas I wanted to
read this as a question that was put to
mr. robb
hello I wanted to put a question that
was was raised with Professor Ellis
deviously
that was that rack of virgins in Iraq
fitting them with the American
revolutionaries and I thought that the
embassy and professor Ellis did draw
that equation sort of and my question is
don't you think that T Harrison
revolutionaries were basically fighting
against the idea of a monarchy in
England and isn't that really more or
less what they're fighting against in
Iraq against bottoms whose same type of
governance which the insurgency's are
basically trying is the insurgents in
Iraq are basically trying to reinstitute
well I
I strongly differ with those who see the
insurgents in Iraq as anything like the
people who fought in our Revolutionary
War the Americans who fought for
the glorious cause of America as they
said then what we were fighting for was
freedom of opinion freedom of religion
freedom of speech freedom to think for
ourselves most of the people who are
involved in the insurgency's in Iraq the
terrorists I really believe in an
entirely different faith there they're
fighting for enforced ignorant and we
don't believe in that and I think it's a
a grave mistake and a great injustice to
the people who led our revolution to
compare the insurgents or the terrorists
San Antonio Texas
yes it's McCullough yes sir
Jeff T Black Arts San Antonio Texas how
are you sir
fine thank you sir with all due respect
it's an honor and a privilege and as a
matter of fact a guiding light to me
personally and I am NOT a young man
anymore
I have done my degrees and my time in
the military time in life and on back in
school in mass media and the great
extent sir do to you and I'll tell you
if I may ask do you think this voice has
any any future in narration yes I think
you definitely have a future
go for it given that then let me let me
go ahead here the work with Ken Burns
that you've done over the years
I remember Shelby Foote saying the Civil
War was the defining moment essentially
for the United States given your work
was 1776 how would you relate that
statement to I mean okay
slavery was the the snake coiled under
the table so to speak and the the wolf
held by the years that Jefferson said
don't let it go type thing we're where
can you relate 1776 to the Civil War
bring it bring it forward from there and
the leaders thank you
well I think that the Revolutionary War
was the most important war in our
history because it's the war that
brought us into being it was the birth
of the nation and if one was to choose
defining moments I'd say that was the
defining moment and I think that the
that the leadership the while it was
Emmett they were amateurs to begin with
they learned as they went along and they
learned from their mistakes
and we were very blessed indeed about as
lucky as we could have been in the
Washington was the leader and emerged as
the leader and I think that Washington
is the most important American American
ever and the most important president
ever even more than Lincoln because
Washington was number one and he set the
standard he set the style and he did
almost everything exactly right his
feeling that he had to hold the country
together he was a say he himself was the
symbol of unity they that held us
together in what could have been
disastrous years at the beginning
because all of that tension that that
friction between the North and the South
between one geographical section of the
country and another mostly over slavery
was already beginning to break the
country apart then and it was washed it
more than anything else who helped hold
it together I'm sitting here and I'm
sure our camera can see the group of
people who have gathered around here do
you feel when when you're surrounded by
people who read your book all the people
who were in the tent people stopped walk
up to you on the street I love it I love
it and and I'm always glad to to meet
them because I want my work to reach
other readers other people who care
about ideas and and who
who love books and I'm very heartened by
the growing interest in history you can
see it all around and it's in it it's
needed because we're raising children
who are by and large historically
illiterate that we've got to change that
but the success of the History Channel
the large audience for the the Ken Burns
Civil War series the fact that books of
the kind that I and others write will
reach large audiences now I think it's
very encouraging and I also think that
it's encouraging in this in the sense
that that the reading of books is by no
means a declining part of life in this
country if anything is it's increasing
its growth getting stronger there's a
tendency among many people and we're
mirages with messages to this effect
that information is learning that all
you have to do is press a button and get
the information and that's going to be
learning information isn't learning
learning comes from books teachers and
hard work hard application thinking I'm
often asked how much in my time I spend
on research and how much I spend on
writing which is a fine question very
seldom am I asked how much of your time
you spend thinking and that's often what
takes the most time and should and
there's something about the written word
there's something about writing that
focuses the mind as nothing else does
you've had the experience yourself when
you writing a letter or writing
something that you want to say and in
the process of writing ideas suddenly
come to you that you would never have if
you weren't writing and nobody knows
quite why that is but it does happen and
that's what also why it's so important
for children in school and in college to
do a lot of writing because it it
exercises the brains the calisthenics of
the brain that the brain needs and we
need to we need to remember that amnesia
can affect in a detrimental way a
society every bit as much as it can an
individual man or woman and if we lose
touch with our past of who we are how we
got where we are and all that but we're
in the soup it's and particularly in the
government that's a representative
government we're the government and and
Jefferson said it perfectly he said any
nation that expects to be ignorant and
free expects what never was and never
can be
Huntington Beach California ah you're
talking about mr. Jefferson and he's
exactly the one I wanted to talk with
you about how could he have been such a
great Patriot and such a backstabber at
the same time he stabbed John Adams in
the back so man I'm half the way through
John Adams and you bring those people to
life so vividly for me I bet I was so
surprised about Jefferson will you talk
to us about him please well none of them
were perfect every one of them was a
human being with his or her individual
failings weaknesses moments when they
did not behave as we would like to think
they did and Jefferson's betrayal of
Adams is is a horrible thing
I think what's wonderful is that Adams
forgave him and that they patched up
their their relationship with each other
and began to communicate once again
through some of the greatest letters in
our history written in the last 15 years
or so of their lives excuse me
Thomas Jefferson was a very great man
Thomas Jefferson put into words the
deepest desires and aspirations of our
of our national soul if you will and his
his inspiration his
we'll live forever but of course he was
a contradiction in terms in his own life
how could a man who wrote all men are
created equal
lived by the labor of slave men women
and children it's hard for us to
understand it was hard for many to
understand then it isn't just that we
look back on it now and feel that way
John Adams and Abigail Adams never owned
a slave as a matter of principle and
they understood as Abigail Adams said
that it was a synth but Adams too had
his own problems he could be wrist Leah
and jealous and vain but what's so
wonderful is that these imperfect human
beings could rise to the occasion and do
what was so extraordinary that's the
story
for me if they were gods as they are
sometimes portrayed they wouldn't
deserve much credit would this because
gods after all could do whatever they
want
these were fallible very human beings
who brought us something almost
miraculous
and the more you read about the
Revolutionary War and that era the bori
you come to the conclusion that it was a
miracle that it ever turned out the way
it did the role of the part played by
chance by the directions of the wind on
a given night the peculiarities or
strength of individual personalities is
is the pivotal event again and again
and also the more one reason reads about
the more fascinating it becomes last
call for David McCullough is from
Kittery Maine hello go ahead kid ring
Lam you're on the air Kittery Maine
hello one last chance hello
Montgomery Texas why don't you try
okay this is Ralph Davis in Montgomery
Texas I'd like to ask David McCullough
his opinion of the books by Durant and
his wife the history of civilization the
11 volumes that were written many years
ago I read his history almost constantly
and I read about half in his fine book I
wonder if he could give me a his opinion
of that well will and aureole I guess
sir at Durant I guess that's the way you
pronounce her name we're a big popular
favorite in their time and and wrote
over and over many volumes about the
history of civilization I read one or
two of them at the time they were
published I guess that would have been
in the 1950s if I'm not mistaken I
thought they were wonderful I did not
read them all and I haven't read them
since then so I'd probably ought to go
back and take another look but they they
certainly reached a large audience and
had a profound effect I think on many
readers all over the country thank you
so much for spending some time with us
today my pleasure I was just looking
around I see some of those very young
people you were talking about with their
books like this holding together okay I
just like to say I think one of the I
love this event I think the book
festival is one of the great events of
the year
and is wonderful how many Americans are
coming from all over the country to be
here but I think the number of young
people here is the one of the most
encouraging and and inspiring aspects of
the whole thing it's a it's great fun
and everybody's everybody's feeling good
I fly in thanks again appreciated we are
live at the National Book Festival with
David McCullough we are now going to
show you just a short clip from last
night that you can see a little bit of
the gala which mr. McCullough